[Musique]
pour les gars je pense qu'on commence à
être pas mal hein y'a tout jamais à
faire il ya l'électroménager mais je
trouve que ça manque un peu de vie
encore dans la partie du coup j'ai pensé
à une pote à moi qui est décoratrice
d'intérieur elle va arriver à 20 pimpi
tout ça je pense que ça va être comme à
la base je crois qu'elle est là à les
niveaux aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe ça me lasse
pas ça va ou quoi super flattée pensé à
moi pour parler des cons
[Musique]
par contre je fume trois gt enveloppe
sept grands noms je m'attaque h une
habituée des blogs et en plus on va
faire un avant/après de malade juste
aider à rentrer des sacs ils sont là
devant l'entrée au quotidien je te passe
juste les caméras bon les gars c'est
trop stylé la chine rapport de ryad on
va le refaire vous connaissez ça va être
le feu les attend ça va tu te
débrouilles c'est parce qu'ils sont lors
de ouf la d51 donc ce qu'il ya dedans
c'est une surprise donc je peux rien te
dis
je pas fan fan des surprises mais
n'inquiètent mais c'est papa qui
cherchèrent un fauteuil de gamer trop
stylé ainsi s'il y en a un juste combat
chez toi tu devrais grammy d'aller à
rien alors maintenant je te suis tu
apprends lieu avant quelqu'un locative
est juste me fais pas trop de vin grec
n'attend que j'arrivais ya max des
légats histoire de malades regardez ce
que j'ai trouvé un style screaming
loulous ya un mec qui sait attitude je
dis monsieur ca ou hindi ouais c'est
vous qui l'avez jeter et me dit non mais
qui voulait pas lâcher la faire je vais
lâcher 10 balles pourvoir le siège
millénaire bien incroyable je pense
qu'il va aller trop bien que
l'appartement je te rends compte en
attendant secondes et fermer les yeux je
ferme pas les yeux jambon bruit c'est
bonjour à la surprise quand même ferme
les yeux je t'ai des hoquets fais moi
confiance je déteste les surprises en
inquiète je sais que tu vas adorer tu
bouges pas à droite ouvre les yeux tu es
prêt 1
e3
ce qui s'est passé quoi ça c'est grâce
au stylet sa charge sa part pas baver
sur une hausse des cadences de travail
du coup je t'ai pris une pointure en ai
dit mais lille pour être sûr que ça ne
bouge jamais ensuite je t'ai pris un
papier effet gazon parce que je sais que
ma ponctuent adore le foot avec des
fesses le foot fait du basket oui bon
c'est les mêmes sports et ensuite
j'étais pris un assortiment de nos
jardins que j'ai trouvé chez ma grand
mère mais je trouvais que des airs est
tellement mieux chez soi un populisme
teddy quoi cette plaine ont semblé pas
n'aurait pas fait ça donc c'est pour ça
que je suis là c'est pour te donner des
idées auxquelles tu n'aurais jamais
pensé et je suis ravi de savoir que ça
te plaît mais je suis pas un menteur je
m'y attendais en tout cas en ce qui
concerne le fauteuil n'est vraiment pas
mal mais mérite un petit coup de
peinture alors que c'est pas de
m'appeler pour ça je vais vraiment
raffiné jeu rendez-vous bélisle abonnés
à les jo
c'était malade
si tous les pilotes
[Musique]
à l'edf oui c'est ryad en fait je vous
appelle pour je pense que c'est en
dehors de vos compétences mais comme
vous êtes la seule personne de mon
entourage qu'un cerveau j'aimerais
savoir si vous aviez encore des bons
plans pour reprendre mon appartement
pour faire la déco et bien toujours sur
votre implication tchèque vous avez des
bons plans pour faire repeindre votre
appartement des réductions pour la
décoration ça devrait pouvoir vous aider
je crois qu'il faut c'est un nom je vous
laisse je voulais ce nom
c'est super ah bah ça fait plaisir de
voir ici franchement en vrai comme ça je
vous vois ça ah bah moi aussi je suis
content de voir en vrai trésor est assez
rare que les clients ont vite a concédé
face à crémaillère - le dévot amis j'ai
sont pas encore là ah non en fait j'ai
invité et que les gens qui m'ont aidé
donc
allez vous
voulez mettre un peu de musique un break
avec plaisir vous voulez un truc en
particulier ou vendre on joue un peu
tous les âges oublie de m'occuper
d'internet a alors de me dire que je dis
toujours la même chose mais
l'application check il ya des bons plans
pour internet pour la fibre piqué sont
ils oui tu vois même
c'est vraiment quelqu'un d'incroyable
habite avec moi vous voulez vous faire
une colonne j'en parle à ma femme mais
pourquoi vous avez une femme on
l'appelle et on demande à l'est
[Musique]